for months only the locals of grace the
beaches applier de Parma in Majorca in
the last 24 hours things have changed
hundreds of German tourists have arrived
and thousands more are coming it's
welcome news for the owner of this bar
which reopened recently but with few
customers
the Germans are this resorts major
tourists Jaromir ma buoni Forenza por
ejemplo monetary ax in Boca
significative I know the case of London
in true inventor I'm trying the % & o
saisons
Bogota Miami if the Germans congregate
here UK tourists head for other sandy
pastures drive 30 minutes west and
you'll come to the resort famous for
British imports from pub names to food
and holiday makers but there are no
tourists here now and in Magaluf you'll
find bar owners with none of the
optimism of down the road they've heard
talk of UK visitors having to quarantine
arriving
I would like to quarantine every turn
you know that I'm going abroad because
then the other quarantine for two weeks
after you going on holidays for two
weeks like you know you're out you know
they're gonna put them on this is
Magaluf s-- most famous street the
center of the nightlife where at this
time of year and all through the summer
you'd expect to find thousands of UK
tourists partying into the early hours
but everywhere is closed they're waiting
for the tourists Spain had said that UK
tourists would be included in those
Europeans allowed to enter the country
from this weekend but the government is
still considering quarantine something
the UK is demanding as Spaniards
traveling in the other direction
still the Spanish government hasn't
decided whether this is going to work
based on epidemiological grades is it
going to be based on you know other
criteria reciprocity for example so it's
still in the air I wouldn't say they can
come and I wouldn't say they cannot come
I think it's still to be decided in the
next days is it possible they can come
but have to go to inter quarantine it is
possible
there's a words unlikely to stir
optimism in those desperate to fill the
bars beaches and sun beds in places like
magaluf or the UK travellers who usually
come in
thousands Michele Clifford skynews
Majorca